hello and welcome to cloud minute today  I'm going to talk about managing SSH  keys on Google compute engine instances  one of the challenges many teams face is  controlling who has SSH access to their  compute engine resources there are a lot  of ways to do this with code including  various scripts and tools but compute  engine provides a way to do it from the  web UI as well from Google Cloud console  click compute engine metadata and then  click SSH keys now to add an SSH key I  click here you paste the whole key in  and you click Save and the SSH keys are  propagated out to all the compute engine  resources in your project let's test it  out you can see I have SSH access to  that compute engine resource when it  comes time to revoke the key click Edit  click the X and then click Save  and now you see I get a permission  denied error so if you've been  struggling to control or audit the SSH  access to your project to try this out